not much time will be gained athenians
in return for the evil name which you
will get
for killing socrates if you had waited a
little while
your desire would have been fulfilled in
the course of nature
for i am old and not far from death
you think that i was convicted through
deficiency of words
i mean that if i had thought fit to
leave nothing undone
nothing unsaid i might have gained an
acquittal
but i had not the boldness or impudence
or inclination
to address you as you would have liked
me to address you
weeping and wailing and lamenting and
saying and doing many things which you
have been accustomed to hear from others
and which are unworthy of me but i don't
regret my defense
i would rather die having spoken after
my manner
then speak in your manner and live for
often in battle
there is no doubt that if a man will
throw away his arms
and fall on his knees before his
pursuers he may escape
death and in other dangers there are
other ways of escaping death
if a man is willing to say and do
anything the difficulty my friends is
not in avoiding death
but in avoiding unrighteousness for that
runs faster than death
i mold and move slowly and my accusers
are keen and quick
and the foster runner who is
unrighteousness has overtaken me
me you have killed because you wanted to
escape the accuser
and not to give an account of your lives
if you think that by killing men
you can avoid the accuser criticizing
your lives you are mistaken
there is not a way of escape which is
either possible or honorable
the easiest and noblest way is not to be
crushing others
but to be improving yourselves till now
the oracle within me
has constantly been in the habit of
warning me was i going to make a slip
or error but now that has come upon me
that which is generally believed to be
the last and worst evil but the oracle
made no sign of opposition
either as i was leaving my house and
going out in the morning
or when i was going up into this court
or
while i was speaking what do i take to
be the explanation of this
i will tell you i regard this as a proof
that
what has happened to me is a good and
that
those of us who think that death is an
evil are in error
either death is a state of nothingness
and utter unconsciousness
or as men say there is a change in
migration of the soul
from this world to another now if you
suppose that there is no consciousness
but asleep like the sleep of him who is
undisturbed
even by the sight of dreams death will
be an unspeakable game
for if a person were to select the night
on which his sleep was undisturbed even
by dreams
and where to compare with this the other
days and nights of his life
and then were to tell us how many days
and nights he had passed in the course
of his life better and more pleasantly
than this one
i think that any man will not find such
days or nights
when compared with the others now if
death is like this
i say that to dies gain for
eternities than only a single night but
if
death is the journey to another place
and there as men say all the dead are
what good could be greater than this
what would not a man give if he might
converse with or fears and homer
nay if this be true let me die again
and again i too shall have a wonderful
interest in a place where i can converse
with ajax
and other heroes of old who have
suffered death
through an unjust judgment and there
will be no small pleasure as i think
in comparing my own suffering with
theirs
above all i shall be able to continue my
search into true and false knowledge
as in this world so also in that i shall
find out who is wise
and who pretends to be wise and is not
for in that world
they do not put a man to death for this
certainly not
for besides being happier in that world
than this
they will be immortal if what is said is
true
wherefore judges be of good cheer about
death
and know this of a truth that no evil
can happen to a good man
either in life or after death he and his
deeds are not neglected by the gods
nor has my own approaching end happen by
mere chance
but i see clearly that to die and be
released was better for me
and therefore the oracle gave no sign
for which reason also i'm not angry with
my accusers or my condemners
they have done me no harm although
neither of them
meant to do me any good and for this i
may
gently blame them the hour of departure
has arrived
and we go our ways i to die and you to
live
which is better god only knows
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like
subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below something cool please so
that
more people can discover it if you want
to watch more videos from my channel
check out this
one and this one take care see you soon
adrian out